[Music]
it was quiet for all these years after
Samuel and I have lost our daughter we
prayed to see our girl again
the contact had started small but she
wanted permission to move into the doll
we soon realized it wasn't our daughter
so we locked it away we thought helping
the girls could be our penance this is
our new orphanage Wow big as it can so
we ended up giving it just what it
wanted you need help
Chester you always say that even though
we have C hard we can feel his presence
in this house
I feel different kind of prisms and even
one is coming after me
fiercely blue easiest you help me what
you need
[Applause]
are you okay Janice found a stall
what doll donut way dress you mustn't go
near that dog
[Applause]
she can walk forgive me sister
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whose room is this anyways no one's had
a daughter it was hers had one I think
she died I think that was her playing
the music - hey why are we in here
and what is it we shouldn't be in here
Janice I told you not to use that room
[Music]
[Applause]
you need sleep that's gonna help you
with the healing I can't stay here
sister Charlotte you can't stay here we
need to leave leave and go where there
isn't anywhere else for us to go I
didn't fall down those stairs something
threw me what do you mean you always say
that even though we can't see God we can
we can feel his presence well in this
house I feel different kind of prisons
what kind an evil woman she wanted
permission to move into the doll so she
could be with us forever
we said yes and that's when it became
stronger mr. powers
that's why she's in bed all day but at
night she go wherever she wants
she needs to so she can see and if you
look directly at her you'll die and to
get you to look she'll keep saying your
name over Nancy Nancy Nancy No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is our new orphanage bring us a
constant feel free to use the house as
you see fit
mrs. Mullins and I stated down here your
rooms are upstairs locked it stays that
way
[Music]
[Music]
Judith says he's seen your daughter my
daughter has been dead for a long time
she was taken from us an early age
[Music]
I prayed to the young loved' girl again
the contact started small but they
wanted permission to move into old dolls
so that it could be with us forever
we said yes who really for presents
it's because I'm the weakest the doll
[Music]
[Music]
ridiculously frightened it's good that
was terrifying
feel free to use the house as you see
fit
you Janey's new babysitter's right it's
the dog devil
Jeanne babysitter's are here I made the
best for you
it'll brew my parse on here we go
oh this is a city thing today it's total
relief it's all over I'm still shaking
it's really horrifying yeah this is
something else I want to check Mahara
right next Eric and that's high it was
amazing I was not expecting that I feel
like the world's worst face it we didn't
really look after her I don't care
it's a really incredible experience I've
lost my voice I've screamed so much I
just couldn't say again I go home now
please I'll be forwarding my psychiatry
pills understand you know the bill for
new underwear
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]